le otorga derechos muy importantes
primero la posibilidad de modificar con
un trámite muy simple su identidad y su
género en el documento nacional de
identidad y en todos los documentos que
identifican a la persona puede definirlo
como la persona lo desee de hecho más
recientemente además si se incorporó una
modificación extra que permitía también
incluir en la opción no binario en el
dni en el documento nacional de
identidad que recuerdo es el documento
que permite hacer todo tipo de trámites
en argentina tanto en el sector público
como en el privado pero además le da la
posibilidad a la persona que así lo
desee a acceder a tratamientos
hormonales para poder desarrollar
también en el plano físico esa identidad
de género ahora bien ahí todavía falta
un poco del lado del cumplimiento pero
fue muy importante porque además a
partir de salir empezaron a aparecer
otras leyes vinculadas con los derechos
de género y los derechos de la mujer
también de alguna forma algunos
establecen un vínculo en esa especie de
línea de derechos que se fueron
adquiriendo entre esta ley de identidad
de género luego
a la aparición de la ley del aborto
legal en argentina es mucho más reciente
hace dos años y también en forma más
reciente aún hace un año la ley de cupo
laboral trans que permite
perdón obliga al sector público por lo
menos a la administración pública
nacional a tener un mínimo de personas
trans en su plantilla de empleo es algo
que de vuelta no se termina de cumplir
efectivamente en todos lados pero está
ahí presente como ley es una garantía de
derechos para éstas para estas personas